mon cher neveu
j'espère que ce cas d'auto claira
léonard leonardi habitants eh bien si
c'est un cas le sujet regarde regarde
mon oncle archibald m'a envoyé un énorme
cadeau enfin si j'ai besoin vite de
l'ouvrir je me demande bien ce que c'est
parfois oui oui
oui il me semble encore plus curieux que
moi apprend casimir que chez moi ce
n'est pas de la curiosité c'est la soif
de savoir le besoin d'apprendre l'envi
chaque jour de découvrir de nouveaux
mois ouais bon évidemment si je lisais
la lettre jusqu'au bout je saurai tout
de suite ce que c'est seulement je
préfèrerais essayer de deviner à vos
excellentes exercice d'imagination
voilà dix mois c'est peut-être un énorme
gâteau une gigantesque pièce montée
peut-être mais à mon avis ce serait plus
large du pain à tu as raison je compris
alors attends on sait c'est peut-être
une belle statue en marbre pour décorer
le jardin pourquoi pas mais je crois que
ce serait plus lourd oui certainement
oui attends je pense que c'est un beau
traversin - le pour appuyer ma petite
tête dans mon niveau lee c'est dans les
choses possibles mais il ne tiendrait
pas si bien debout voiture ou alors la
honte là encore raison à sion les
cherche encore non non non je ne peux
plus attendre alors vas-y retire la
toile la forêt attention plus quel
instant émouvant après les attentions
rampeau
pas mal
il est très beau
très décoratif oui oui c'est beau c'est
décoratif
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc machin
chose à moi comment mais c'est un
portemanteau par 10 arrêts importants
mais à quoi ça sert comment dit qu un
portemanteau lazimi cela s'est
raccrochée des manteaux voilà bah oui la
corne
je ne vois vraiment pas pourquoi ils
m'envoient ça je ne porte jamais de ma
peau moite one ou les d'autres gens
portent des moutons plein ça c'est vrai
alors là là là j'ai une idée une idée
j'espère une idée signée kazimiyah est
toujours une idée géniale tu vas voir
je ne préfère pas allez salut je ne
préfère pas hollande ou la
sole
ça m'énerve sol
sol sol oh la la la main
martin en feintant bas qu'est ce que
c'est tout ce bruit neige tu n'as pas la
contemple non je suis pas contente ça
m'énerve ce n'est pas une raison pour
casser ton violoncelle quand même mais
j'ai des problèmes avec mon sol un brin
le dire plutôt qu'une atteinte changer
car l'ajout de plancher ou je sais pas
ou mal d'éléments quelqu'un c'est très
jeune il a manqué de la moquette sur mon
violoncelle au mais où je sais pas du
ciment par an vers tient en verre comme
ça c'est très bon mais c'est pas mon
blanche et qu'il ya des problèmes c'est
mon sol do ré mi fa sol sol mais quand
même ça y est mais quel bruit mais avec
un peu ma femme mais que se passe-t-il
vous ne pourriez pas accorder vos
violons mais c'est pas un violon c'est
un violoncelle non mais c'est sur le
sexe et un violoncelle mais accorder ses
violons est une expression qui veut dire
se mettre d'accord parler de la même
chose voire bon quel était le sujet de
votre polémique mais je disais que
j'avais des problèmes avec mon sol et
les aux normes parle de moquette aux
moquettes enfin mélo en art il n'y a pas
que l'amour charisme ben voilà ainsi
chez moi mon sens les scieries c'est
beaucoup plus économique non non et non
moi c'est le seul de mon violoncelle qui
est trop bas la note sal seul ça sonne
l'alarmé
vous voyez il suffit il accorder ses
violons mais c'est pas un violon n'a
vraiment vous n'êtes pas des artistes
vous ne comprenez rien à la musique vous
deux la musique oui la musique à
doha
justement à propos de sol quel poids
sont délicieux j'en ai mangé une amie
dit
une seule manière c'est excellent les
phénix au
[Musique]
sol do ré mi fa sol sol sol si curieux
casimir a vraiment de drôles quitter
bonjour notre jamais faux monsieur qui
s'appelait effet vous semblez pensive
perplexe son jeu et bien oui figurez
vous que je viens de recevoir une
invitation de casimir très curieuse
écoutez plutôt je serais très heureux
que tu viens de voir un verre de
limonade à la maison tenue manteau
exigible je sais cher ami je sais j'ai
reçu la même invitation et même françois
que je vais le rencontrer et on avait
mis un manteau il partait chez casimir
imminente pour toi peut-être que casimir
auteurs que nous prenions froid
vous savez qu avec casimir ya longtemps
que j'ai cessé de me poser des questions
ni toi qu'est ce que c'est que ce gros
sacs bien figurez vous qu'il y a deux
manteaux 1 pour vous et bien pour moi
comme c'est gentil j'espère que vous
m'avez apporté
vous savez ce n'est pas particulièrement
le gym en fait c'est somptueux
que l'impatience chers amis nous les
mettrons à la dernière minute ailleurs
c'est l'heure il faut y aller en
outre vous chers amis
casimir on ne sait jamais il vivra verra
ce que je joue avec son mentor moi je
retirais
et voilà
ça lui quasiment pas françois wachnick
on manque d'eau gelée accroché à la
barre hier en arrivant
these mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
idée saugrenue de nous demander de venir
avec un auto en france et c'est pour
pouvoir utiliser le le cas d'où comme un
fait mon oncle archibald
d'accord et je comprends que zynga bon
ben je vais aller rechercher mon manteau
et je vais l'accrocher à ton short
membres non non on n'y va pas c'est pas
la peine qu'on puisse s'y trop tard
maintenant non je vous aurais aimé que
tu le fasses un spontanément que ça
devienne a validé sans coeur sans qu on
en dise sens que j'ai besoin de te
mettre les points sur les i enfin que
veux-tu me déçoit beaucoup froid en pis
ça passera casimir mon vieux je suis
désolé mais je peux pas prévoir que tu
avais un porte-manteau
casimir ton portemanteau me donne l'idée
d'un jeu oh ça c'est une idée comme ça
ça me change a résidé à temps je
cherchais les enfants les enfants venez
venez
venez vite les enfants venez vite
regarder les enfants qu'est ce que c'est
que ça
c'est un portemanteau c'est ce que vous
allez faire vous allez vous promener
dans la maison de casimir et vous y
trouverez un certain nombre d'objets qui
sont des noms composés dans lesquelles
il ya le mot porte porte quelque chose
et chez vous regardez bien aussi allez-y
et vous nous les apportez
un petit peu partout boj a déjà trouvé
toi un porte clés à porte clés son
anneau qui sert à retenir les clés très
bien un bilan comptable oui qu'est-ce
qu'il ya encore je lui apprends donc à
trouver un porte avions qu'elles
souhaitent qu'un porte-avions
danton qui sont les miens c'est très
bien c'est un navire de guerre c'est pas
un vrai c'est un jouet c'est une macabre
introduction qu'est ce que tu as trouvé
toi
c'est mon porte monnaie mais c'est
presque ça c'est un portefeuille un
portefeuille ça sert à mettre des
papiers et il ya aussi un porte monnaie
mais qu'il n'a pas trouvé un
porte-monnaie pour mettre les pièces non
mais où je l'avais mis là c'est lourd ça
qu'est ce que j'y retrouvais toi pluie
un porte-parapluie ça sert à quoi
et bien sûr et où ça se trouve un porte
parapluie dans une maison en général
donc dans la maison ah oui pour
l'acheter mais dans la maison général ça
se trouve à l'entrée on arrive tout de
suite on est sans parapluie remarque le
mar diop est ce que c'est que ça dedans
c'est un porte bonheur ça s'appelle un
trèfle à quatre feuilles pourquoi c'est
un porte bonheur
parce que c'est très rare un trèfle à
quatre feuilles en général ça ne fait
que trois feuilles comme c'est très rare
quand on en trouve un audi que ça porte
bonheur ces facteurs qui l'a trouvée
pendant sa tournée vous avez tous où
j'en vois une autre je vais le chercher
là bas
qu'est ce que c'est que ça les enfants
apportent savons
tu as raison et où ça ça me rapporte sa
voix
à la baignoire
un porte-voix comment sont certes on a
portelois fait comme sarah qui voit là
c'est pour parler à quelqu'un qui est
très loin pour porter la voix même s' il
prend je vous ai appelé françois ii
voilà c'est ça au bout du jardin tu
prends le porte-voix et avant la case i
met your man oui amusant ce genre il en
a oublié un nom mon équipe un peu plus
mince ah oui n'importe quoi mon petit
penser le temps des porte-plumes pour
écrire des souvenirs
pour la sogeta plus kazim il met ainsi
fin aux siens ça m'a beaucoup plu mais
ça m'a vraiment épuisée au long bow asir
je tiens plus debout frau la gazinière
je peux faire quelque chose pour toi mon
vieux oui françois j'aimerais que tu te
transformes
emporte casimir
à ma chère amie vous êtes reste plan dix
ans vous superbe merci beaucoup
bonjour mon bouquin de 1000 entrées dont
vous me donnez moi vos manteaux quand je
les accroche au cadeau de mon oncle
archibald ah non pas question venons à
peine de les mettre enfin si vous
refusez d'utiliser ce porte manteau le
cadeau le servira jamais rien
enfin bon jour et un verre de limonade
bien sûr dessin venir frais voilà
si vous si vous voyez la fête que vous
avez avec ses manteaux je viens tous les
ans les varier leur suite
bobobo casimir d'un corps j'enlève ma
moto je crois que je vais en faire
autant parce que moi je suffoque et aux
normands tout
mon portemanteau
kazim ou
écoutent vraiment tuant régulière la
nette de tonton hashim un jusqu'au bout
et surtout taïmyr la croche rien à son
portemanteau il est très vieux c'est une
pièce de musée le bois est entièrement
rongé par l'hiver il est donc très
fragile
pour mon pauvre vieux portemanteau
puisque tu es vieux et usé tu mérite une
bonne retraite mais vous avez si je
rappe en 1 2 voies à accrocher un
manteau amont portemanteau je vous met à
la porte
[Musique]